bonsoir masse m alors le cortège a
démarré
[Musique]
écoutez amira le cortège a démarré il ya
à peu près une heure et dans dix
septième arrondissement
on est sur la venue de didier direction
place de la république
ils sont des centaines de gilets jaunes
à s'être donnés rendez vous depuis 10h
et puis là pour le moment on est encore
sur l'avenue vivier un important cordon
de sécurité a été déployé crs gendarmes
et sorties police comme le vin juste
derrière moi il commença erreur quelques
tensions entre les manifestants et les
forces de l'ordre pour le moment c'est
calme depuis le début de cette marche
c'est une revendication que depuis deux
ans et demi c'est gilet jaune qui
demande plus de justice sociale et à
cela s'est ajouté le nouvel ils veulent
de nouvelles choses par rapport
notamment aux restrictions qui ont
découlé des décisions du gouvernement
par rapport à luc chanteau coronavirus
je propose d'écouter certains de ces
jeunes qu'on a pu interviewer en début
de manifestation avec les coronavirus là
je pense qu on a plus de liberté
on n'a plus rien du tout ils vont priver
de tout couvre-feu le port du masque la
liberté du peuple y en a plus les gens
font des dépressions sur des pressions
et il y en a vraiment un ras-le-bol quoi
on est là aussi pour la liberté
on ne veut pas être un peuple soumis nos
anciens ont travaillé pour notre liberté
ils ont travaillé dur et nous en ce
moment nous enlève tout
tout ça pour un gouvernement qui se
croient tout permis et sa non on n'en
veut pas on n'arrive plus à vivre de nos
salaires ne m'en travaillant on peut pas
vivre
on va bientôt être à la rue même avec
des salaires en tant qu'aide soignant
j'ai aussi des colères qui se sont
agglutinés à celle et gilet jaune avait
le manque de moyens le fait de
travailler pour rien donc et encore plus
maintenant dans la compte d'un contexte
sanitaire je trouve que il ya un con il
ya une espèce d'hypocrisie m'inquiète -
du coronavirus que l'état du pays dans
lequel on va être dans dix ans bientôt
on sortira plus une carte vitale pour
aller soigner mais une carte bleue
amiral mêmes revendications pour sécher
des jaunes qui sont déterminés à se
faire entendre
encore une fois et profiter de cette
manifestation du 1er mai comme toute
autre manifestation sur
l'ensemble du territoire parisien toutes
ces manifestations qui vont converger
sur la place de la république pour
l'instant nous on est encore dans le 17e
arrondissement ça marche doucement des
forces de l'ordre quadrillent vraiment
cette centaine de manifestants de ces
gilet jaune avec les mêmes slogans
depuis deux ans hostiles au gouvernement
estime emmanuel macron sans quelques
tensions comme une attention est assez
palpable même si l'ambiance reste plutôt
bon enfant ça chante qui des tambours
également accompagne ce cortège ça
marche et ça s'arrête si tu marches
assez lente
ici dans différents arrondissements mes
objectifs de ces gilet jaune rejoindre
bien sûr le parcours qui a été énoncé
par la préfecture la place de la
république pour retrouver les autres
manifestations cette journée si du 1er
mai merci abbas m ont fait le point avec
vous tout à l'heure